我来分享一下屏幕
大家能看到我的屏幕
对 首先还是非常感谢义东和T沙龙的邀请
因为说实话 疫情之后我也很久没有参与过这种
无论是线下还是线上的分享
所以今天也是比较荣幸能够在这边给大家分享一些
也跟Y怎么相关的情内容
同学也感谢大家能够在工作日的晚上来参加这样一次活动
然后今天我这边可能还是给大家讲一讲Y怎么相关的内容
那我可能也不会说讲的太deep dive
所以我的希望是说能够希望通过这次分享
能够让一些同学如果对这个技术感兴趣
那能够给你一些帮助
那如果说你以前已经了解Bob Salmon的话
那我觉得我们可以一起再来看一看
比如说在这个2022年这个时间节点上
那Y怎么在整个业绩的一个情况是什么样子的
好吧
然后那惯例我们先来对一个简单的自我介绍
对我叫于航
然后呢大家可以叫我这个Jason
因为Jason也是我在这个工作中会平时
这一个你可以一个英文名吧
可能讲是这方面一点
然后我现在在PayPal做这个这个人家开发
但主要的是Focus在这个前端这块
那我之前2018年的时候
其实是写过一本书叫这个生产书Apple Sampling
那当时呢其实是这个第一门介绍Apple Sampling这样一个书
然后呢在这个分享之后呢
我也会跟大家聊一聊就是更多的一些关于这个写这本书
过程中的一些一些经验吧
我觉得
然后后边我也出过两个专栏
一个是Web3.0的萌克
一个是深入C语程学学员里
然后这两萌克是在极客时间上有发布的
大家如果感情就可以去看一下
我这边的话工作主要是以Web为主
工作之外也会关注一些其他的技术领域
比如说System Programming
还有一些比如说这个操作系统相关的一些东西吧
所以我这边其实除了wibe的话
其实包括这种cxjjj和assembly
就是会边语言可能用的也比较多一些
但是这三个语言本身跟wisem可能也是有关系的
所以你可以理解其实是
wibe是我的主要一个工作
那除此之外呢
从外部演生出来的可能有wibeassembly
然后直至这个整个操作系统相关的内容
这边我都会有所设计
然后后面列的三个链接呢分别是我的blog
还有我的github
然后我的GiHoo
blog上的我这边会经常写一些文章
包括我其实
平时可能看的书稍微多一些
所以我这个每本书都会
记一些我觉得有用的一些
读书笔记版的可以这样理解
如果大家感兴趣可以去稍微扫一眼
看看比如说对你的这个
一些这个技术爱好呀或者说去对你的工作
我一般可能會有一些開員項目
但最近的可能這個代碼貢獻的比較少
那後面可能會做一個跟這個XV6
就是操作系統相關的一個項目
那如果感興學同學可以看一眼
然後智庫上面呢可能也會同步一些
我的這個blog裡的一些文章
那大家如果感興學可以去抽驗
然後呢我們今天主要會介紹這個
Web3.0的一個方便的內容
首先我會講一下
YSM的一個基本的介紹
然後呢
在這個概念的基礎之上我會講一講
我想要去快速做一個簡單的
Web3.0講一個實踐
幫助你能夠快速的
從理論走向這個實踐
去進一步看一下Web3.0是什麼樣的內容
然後呢我們會看一下Web3.0
在目前时间节点的一些进展和案例
最后我们会聊一聊正在行进中的一些Wizom的提案
还有跟它生态相关的那个tooling相关的一些内容
最后我们看一看在2022年这个时间节点
从社区的角度来看Wizom它整个的趋势是什么样子
这一点我们会从多个方面来整体看一下Wizom的一个情况
然后呢,首先这个我们讲,我们来看一下这个web3.0是什么,那如果大家之前没有这个关注过,那我觉得可以通过这一小节的介绍来对
我怎么讲一个技术有一个基本的认知,那web3.0其实你把这个字拆分来看,你会发现它其实有两个部分,一个是这个web,一个是assembly
所以我们说其实Web Summit这个技术本身是发愿与Web的
所以你可以这样连理解
那实际上我们可以对照着来看
比如说我在Web Summit变身之前我们来看一看
在Web怎么出现之前我的这个Web平台上的这个应用架构什么样子
那我们都知道其实我们写前端写Web并用用的最多的就是JavaScript对吧
所以我们可以来看一下
我去運行一段GS代碼,它的整個路徑是什麼樣子呢?
這邊我以V8為例,就V8引擎為例,我們來看一下
首先我有一個GS的Source Code,然後我把它餵給這個引擎
然後引擎會經過幾個階段來把代碼最終執行出來
首先它會通過Passor
會生成對應的這樣一個抽象與法術
然後通過Interpreter這樣一個解釋器
我能夠生成處於中間位置的這樣一個階碼
然後在抹黑情況下
比如說我的這個引擎
它發現你的一單代碼可能運行了100次
那這100次或者是1000次
運行了很多次
然後它發現這1000次裡
你運行的代碼的邏輯都是一樣的
那這個時候呢
我的這個 engine
就會通過 Justin Time 這樣一個
這層引擎把你的這個代碼編譯成跟機器碼
然後呢
你更快的這樣一個效率去執行
所以這裡是我們說的這個
從 backcode 到優化的機器碼
這樣一個 compiling 這樣一個過程
但是呢這個過程也不是一直
一直會持續進行的
在某些情況下它可能會通過這種
这种de-optimized 这种方式把你的这个优化的机器码回退到我们之前的这样一个bitecode
那我们可以看到其实整个GS的执行流程其实是蛮长的对吧
你要经过passer 经过interpreter 还要配合这个我们说profiler
就是去收集我在分析这段代码或者在运行这段代码中的一些原数据
比如說哪些function它是hot它是熱帶碼
那哪些路徑上是hot是熱帶碼
那我通過profiler我會把它收集起來
最後結合我的這個原代碼和batcode
然後再加上這個profiler data
我再去把它轉成優化的機器碼
然後再去執行
所以你看到這些鏈路很長
那這個是我們說js的一個執行流程
那除了這個我們剛才說的
本身GS代码要经过传统的编译和类型一系列环节之后
其实作为一个动态类型的语言
GS在真正实在执行的时候
它真正消耗性能的地方
其实更多的是体现在它的动态性上
比如说我们这边举个例子
比如说我们看一表是X加Y
其实X加Y这个表是很简单
但是呢实际上你去让这个v8也好啊
或者其他的js engine去执行
这个表示的时候呢实际上它是非常非常复杂的
你可以看到左边我这个图啊
其实
我的边线引擎
那我的这个这个js引擎再去执行这个
呃expression的时候
它其实直到我真正
遇到了x和y的时候
我才能够知道
我的xy具体什么类型
所以呢它需要经过
我左边给的这一些一系列环节来去说
在XY比如说什么种类型的情况下
那我应该是怎么样去执行
这个加号这个运算幅的过程
所以它需要很多很多流程
比如说我X可以是个Object
Y可以是String
那我X甚至是可以是个Function
Y也可以是个Number
那在这种不同的这种动态类型的组合下
其实编辑或者说这个Engine它其实是需要
需要消耗很多其他的一些資源也好
需要消耗很多其他的這種分析
來去得到這個表示的這種結果
所以我們可以看到其實動態性
其實是GS本身性能沒法進一步提升的
一個比較重要的阻礙
那這也說我們講為什麼說
我在上一個步驟中
那個鍊路中會存在
deoptimization這樣一個去油化的過程
那其實我的這頂引擎在
在真正去執行的時候
比如說我們拿這種最簡單的Trace State
這種方式來說的話
其實Trace State的需要去先識別
比如說我哪一段代碼是這個Hot代碼
是熱代碼
然後我需要去把它記錄下來
成為一個Trace Lat
但是Trace Lat被編譯成二斤製的機器碼之後
它其實在執行的時候
需要保證說
我这个TraceNet能够满足一些预定的条件
那我可能举一个不唱的例子
比如说我这个代码在编译的过程中
我遇到了一个循环
那这个循环领的可能有
这个它需要循环一万次
我举一个不太不太唱的例子
比如说它循环一万次
ok 那我执行到第一千次的时候
我的这个界定引擎或者说profiler发现
ok 我这个循环好像执行的一千次都是一样的
那我能不能把剩下那些次的代碼執行
以這種優化機器碼的形式來執行呢
以一個更高效率的方式來執行呢
那這個時候可能這點已經就會去做編譯了
然後生成堆硬的這個Tristat堆硬的
這個會變代碼也好 機器代碼也好
然後去執行
但是呢 就恰巧
比如說在我第2000次執行的時候
我這個循環語語中有一個語句生效了
然後他把我其中循環執行過程中
用到的某一个变量比方X
它的这个类型做了更改
比如说之前是
Inner是一个整形
然后我在第2000次调整的时候
我把X换成Object
那这个时候我的这个
Chislade它需要去执行满足的条件
就会被破坏掉
也就是说我需要在执行的时候满足X
它是个整形
但是在第2000次的时候发现
OK X不是整形了
所以这个时候呢
我就要去做一个去优化的过程
把我的这个执行路径
退回到我原先的那个Bitecode
也就是字节码的方式来执行
所以可以看到其实这个去优化也好啊
还有说本身GS这个动态性也好啊
其实都是影响我的这个GS代码
执行效率去进一步提升的长远阻碍
那这也是为什么我要去就是在讲
Web3.0之前給大家看一看
就是我在Y怎麼出現之前
我用GS它可能會有什麼的問題
但是GS的出現使得我的情況發生的變好
首先我們來看看什麼是Web3.0
我可能用簡單的概括一下
我可能概括為四個方面
然後我可以通過四個方面
讓你來快速的了解一下
OK
Web3.0究竟是一個什麼東西
從本質上來看
其實Y怎麼它是一套新的
然后抽象的这样一种虚拟机的指令级
对你可以把它对标成比如说我ZX86
或者是ARM的这种会边指令或机器指令
你可以把它作为类比
它那也是一套指令级
只不过它是一种抽象出来的
不局限于任何物理硬件的这样一套虚拟机的指令级
然后它是怎么表现出来的
它是会以二斤G的格式
是被编码在一种名为一种以这个点Y怎么回后军结尾的这样一个二进制的格式里面
那这个二进制的文件其实有一个比较明显的特征
就是如果说你用这种hackstorm或者其他的这种工具来去对它进行这个inspect
因为发现我这个二进制文件的最开头会有这样一传magic code
这个magic code就是原来标识说OK我当前这个文件是什么类型的
它会被各种编辑或者各种训练机
来去作为识别我当前的Wildman文件
是否合法的一个重要的信息
这个MatterCode就是这样一个
十六进去的一个数字
一个字串
它是凌乘6D736100
从这边我给的图你可以看到
其实因为它是小端序
所以我的这个D位
其实位于整个文件的D地址位的
所以左边是零的话
那就是它的第一认为在最左侧
就是006736D这样一个一个形式
ok 那这个是
我说这个Web Summary是怎样来表现的
它是一种点Y的为
1.wsm为后镜结尾的这样一个二净值文件
然后它的这个指令级是以这种
二净值的形式被编码在这个文件里的
那目前进展是什么呢
wb3.0的目前已经可以被4R瀏覽器来直接使用
那也就是wb3.0的MAP版本
它已经被4R瀏覽器可以直接支持所有版本规定的所有指令
也就是说你可以去在这些瀏覽器上直接去使用
这个MAP版本里的所有的指令
那最后一点呢
我需要知道是说OK我先有了这样一个虚拟机的整理机
有了这样一个RG的文件
那我怎么来用呢
实际上为了让Web3.0能够在瀏覽器中正常的使用
那配套的这个WebAPI也是已经提供的
那也就是我们可以通过标准的Web上的Web3.0的API接口
来在瀏覽器中去加载解析和执行
这些点Web5.0RG用文件内的抽象的虚拟机制令
OK,然后我们再把wizom拿回到我们之前的Pathline用来看看
它在整个的Pathline用是一个什么的位置
因为发现其实如果把wizom放进来之后
其实我的wizom的二斤制的代码
其实并不需要前边的传统的这样一个编译的流程
比如说我不再需要通过passer
我不太需要通过Interpreter
那我只需要把二进制的代码直接喂给Compiler
我就能够生成最终的优化的机器
然后来对执行
所以在管线里你会发现它的位置是在这个位置
我可以把上面的所有内容全部都省去
我不太需要Interpreter
我不太需要再生成BadCode
我只需要一个OptimizingCompiler
就能够把我的Web3.0的Bandering
把它编一成最优化的那个版本的极其代码
所以你会发现其实Web3.0在整个的这个链路中
它是非常靠后的
它使得我们这个整个的这个Web应用的执行
相对于JS来说其实整个性能是有一个很大的提升的
所以这个是Web3.0它是什么
它相比于JS它的优势在哪里
然后我们讲完这个基础的里面之后
我们来看一下我怎么来去使用Webassembly
那这里首先为大家来看一个Whism的一个例子
就是Whism本身我刚才讲到
其实它是一种二进制的这样一个指令机对吧
但是为了人们更好地去Inspect
或者说更好地去看说我的这个二进制的指令
它具体的业务逻辑会说这个具体的逻辑是什么样子的
那其实我们整个的这个
YZM也有一个对应的叫WAT这个版本
那WAT翻译过来就是WebSamily Text Permand
也就是说它是这种
我的这个二斤制的YZM模块的一个对应的
人类可读的这样一个文字版本
那它本身是用这个SPR式的形式来去
去描述整个wisemarquard的逻辑的
比如说我们可以看到
这是一个完整的wisemarquard
它对应的WAT文本的一个样子
其实这里边很清晰地描述了
我整个wisemodel它内部哪些内容
比如说我们可以分辨来看一看
首先比如说第二行
这里在这样一个type指令
其实它是定义了我的一个方式类型
其实你按照我这边给的一些计号来读一读
其实也很好理解 对吧
比如 func 那我就是声明一个函数
然后 func右边这个 param
就是声明说OK 我这个function
它是接收几个参数
那每个参数类型是什么
这边写的r32
就跟uniclidity为强
是一个32倍的整数
那这边因为有两个连续的sr
所以表示呢
我这个function
它是接收可以接受两个sr类型的参数的
然后最右侧的就会造成sr的表示说
我这个function在调整完成之后呢
我需要返回给我的调用方
我的这个调用方一个sr类型的整数
也就是它的返回值类型
所以你可以把这一行理解为
比如说我印射到C
或者CaCa中的這個函數簽名
對吧
其實我指定了這個
這個這個猜數類型和反彙劑類型
那我就定義了一個完整的函數簽名
然後再接下來其實是這個函數的函數
函數體部分
就是說我就函數它內部的邏輯是怎樣的
所以你可以看到
這個代碼第四行getlocal0和getlocal1
就第三第五行這兩句話呢
其實說我把我的這個傳入的這個實餐
零就第一個實餐
在依舊第二個實餐給他取出來 對吧
然後最後我通過這個I32.i的
我把這兩個參數進行一個相加
最後得到一個結果
因為我按到後面沒有任何指令了嘛
所以這個表達式
或是這個指令他的結果就會作為返回值
返回給我的這個含述的調研房
所以你看到其实这个逻辑很简单对吧
然后最后这个导书段其实也很好理解
那我们知道其实刘烂契或者说这个外伯平台
其实他本身是作为一个host作为一个宿主方
来去使用外伯三美这样一个这样一个这个这个技术的
就你可理解外伯三美其实他我刚才讲的
外伯三美是他是一个布局限于
它是獨立於平台的一個抽象的訓練機指令器
那既然抽象的話就意味著它其實不僅僅可以使用在外部平台上
所以相對於外部平台來說
我的這個Wizom它就是一個技術的標準
那外部瀏覽器它就是我這個Wizom執行的一個素質環境
所以這裡的Export這樣一個指令就是說
我想把這個Function0也就是我所謂以為0的這樣一個Function
也就是前面我們定的這個Function0
给他导出到我的数据环境中
并且给他取一个名字
identifier
就是一个可识别的一个东西
叫add
所以实际上我们这段
YZM的代码
实际上是定义了一个函数
也就是接收两个函数
并且把两个函数相加
返回出去的这样一个add函数
然后我们既然说
OK 这是我们已经得到了一个
YZM的一个banner位的一个东西
那我怎么去生存这个东西呢
因為不可能說我每一個Y的模具
我都去首寫這樣一個WAT 對吧
這個是不現實的
因為我說現在這個邏輯比較短
這個方式Add比較短
比較簡單
我們可能說首寫
或者直接看清楚
但是一旦我的業務邏輯複雜了
其實我光用首寫指令
肯定是不現實的
所以接下來我們來看一看
我怎麼樣去通過這個
比如說給的一個C和C++代碼
來生成這段WAT代碼
對應的一個Y的模具
就临的,因为我们说要用这个CXCA加代码来生成对应的Visor module,所以就临我会选择使用一个名为imscrapping的这样一个compiling tool,就是这样一个一个一个编译工具链,
它其實為我們提供了可以把C和C++代碼編譯成YZM代碼的這樣一個能力
比如說我現在把一段C代碼給到這個編譯器
它編譯之後可能會生成兩部分內容
一個呢就是我們剛才講的它可能會生成YZM code
裡面包含著WebAssembly的一些二進去指令
然後引起我們的業務邏輯
然后第二个他可能生成的就是JESC LOO
那你可能会问我为什么要生成这样一个JESC LOO呢
最近可以想一下一个例子
比如说我现在有一个C的一个代码
然后这个C代码里边可能会使用我的C标准库
然后去访问一个文件
然后打开这个文件
然后往里写些内容
然后把这个文件关闭
然后退出
这个C代码实际上是做
实际上做了一件事
就是它通过调用一些操心底层的接口
来去进行了一个文件读写的操作
但是你可以想象的是
我在外部流产器上是没法去直接读写
一个宿主计算机上面的一个文件 对吧
那为了去模拟这样一个环境
其实Emicrampon就通过提供这样一个GS的路
其实它是帮我们通过GS来模拟出了这样一个PoSix的一个执行环境
那也就是说假如我把刚才说的那段C代码通过IMSGrapin来去编译
生存最后的代码呢
你会发现我其实处理IO那部分的逻辑实际上是在GS从来实现的
或者你可以说其实IMSGrapin通过GS代码来为我们模拟出了PoSix接口的一些特征
比如說你在C接口端
那我們一般可能會有這種
比如說這種File這樣一個結構體
它就會映射到GS中的一個Object
然後對應自斷可能也都是相同的
所以它其實是完美的
或者說一比一的去復刻了
這樣一個Posting環境
只不過這個環境不是在我們真實的操作系統中
它是在論壇器上通過GS來模擬的
所以我们可以理解说Infopment其实通过JESC的路为我们去模拟了这个Virtual的File System
同时它也会帮我们去模拟其他的一些环境,比如说PeaceRide的环境,比如说LinearMemory的环境
再比如说它可能会用WebGL来替换掉你在C和新加坡里使用的OpenGL接口,那这个都是Infopment会做的事情
OK,然后我们来看,我们现在给学生代码,这个代码是我们刚才讲的这个 ad 函数,对吧?
这是一个简单的,一个 cga 代码,那这里我们看中间那个绿色的 ad 函数,就是我们刚才讲的,
它接受两个整形的参数 xy,然后返回这两个参数的和,然后需要注意的是,
其实这里除了我们去定义这个函数之外
我们还加了一些其他的元素在这个里面
与法元素
比如我们可以看其实
我首先我要把这个Inscript
提供那个投资键可以include进来
因为我在第三行实际上使用了一个红
Inscript and Keep Alive这个红
这个红的作用是保证说
我在编译的时候
我的编译器不会把这个函数
给这个deadcode的elimination去掉
因为这是来说我们这个函数就没有命函数对吧
那在编辑下来看
其实我们命函数里如果没有调整的函数
都是没有用的函数
那他们会选择性的把这个函数给去除掉
那通过加这个红
我们可以确保说
我对中编辑的生生产物里
这个函数是存在的
然后呢我们外边套了AxterC
保证说我这个A的函数不会因为
比如说CA的Mongling
导致它的名字被改变
因为这个函数名字我们要确保它是不会被变化的
这个函数在被编译成外面三百模块之后
它的函数名也是要确保是add
因为我们最后需要在我们的论址器中去调一个函数
所以你不可能说5万名字改了之后我们没法去调用对吧
所以我们需要通过x和c这样一个预发结构来保证
让c二大编译器把中间的add函数当做c函数来进行编译
那保证它的名字是不会变化的
然后我们可以简单的通过一行这个命令行来去完成最后一个编译
这里呢我通过这个杠S这样一个这样一个在意语里面是个标识符吧
来传递给这个emcc也就是imscrapping提供的这个编译器
传给一个flag就是我要生成wism做个target
然后传给杠O3这是一个优化等级
最后通过杠小欧来声明说
OK 我要产出的产物
它是Toy.y怎么这样一个文件
这边之后我们会得到一个点
Y怎么结尾的这样一个RGB文件
OK 现在我们有了Toy.y怎么
那我们怎么来使用它呢
其实也很简单
我刚才提到其实
现代冷冷气的时候
其实已经提供了很多的API接口
来可以让我们来方便的
在瀏覽器中去使用這些WebAssembly的能力
比如說這裡我們就用簡單的幾個API
就能夠把我們Wizom中定義的那個愛的函數給調用出來
首先我通過Fetch
或者說通過其他的這種XHRE號
就是通過這種方式
來獲取到我們Toy.Wizom的一個文件內容
然后这里我们要需要得到它这个文件对应的二进之字节码
也就是以二进之字节码的形式来描述它的内容
这里内容会放到我们第四行的bytes里面
然后我们通过一个名为WebAssembly.extachet这样一个函数
来对bytes 也就是说包含WebAssemblyBattery
这样一个信息的这样一个bites集合来做一个触碩化
那通过这个函数呢
我们就能得到一个完整的已经实力化的
web assembly module
那它会被放在最后的result里面
然后呢我们在通过result上的
instance.export
这样一个一个属性啊
就能够获得我们最终的 ad 函数
然后这个时候我们像普通的这个
js 函数一样去调一下就可以了
我直接传一个10和20
最后呢我们就能得到它的反回值30
所以你可以看到 其實這個Web Summit的使用協也很簡單 對吧
那有了這些這個Web Summit外備片子提供了
其實我保證說我們的用戶 我們的開發者
能夠去方便和靈活地去使用
Web Summit提供的一切能力
所以一共你可以看到 其實我們只有三步 對吧
獲得字節碼 然後實力化 然後調研就OK了
OK 那我們講完了這個
刚才我们介绍了这个这个
蚂蚁蚂蚁一个理论性的这个内容
还有一个简单的实践对吧
接下来我们来看看蚂蚁蚂蚁的一些进展
和一些它在这个生产中的一些案例
那语言这边其实过几例了一部分
就是这边其实真的太多太多了
蚂蚁蚁从这个
应该是17年发展到现在
现在应该也有了五年的时间嘛
那实际上从最开始
比如说下家是最开始支持
编译到为什么这样一个
native language
直到现在其实有很多很多很多这样的语言
都可以支持被编译成外伯三连
那可能有人会好奇啊
为什么这一边
比如说像拍桑这种动态类型的语言
也会为类其中呢
那实际上这个地方我们所说的这个
外伯三连变成语言可以分为两类
那一類的是說我的這個語言本來本身就是有鏡臺類
就是鏡臺類型語言
比如說我的這個Rusty
比如說CIAJIA
比如說assembly script
它本身就是一個鏡臺類型語言
那它其實我把它這個鏡臺類型語言編譯到
WebAssembly需要的信息
本身你這個語言的日代碼上都是能夠提供的
所以我不太需要說什麼額外的信息
我能夠直接把這些語言的日代碼編譯到
WebAssembly的Baner
但是對於拍賞或者說其他的這些動態類型語言來說
其實因為我語言層面其實缺少很多信息
比如像JS來說的話
它其實沒有具體的
或者說我在做靜態大法分析的時候
其實我沒法知道說我每一種數據
每個辨量它什麼類型的
所以我沒法直接硬實到網絡三文
那這類變成語言我們一般怎麼處理呢
我們一般會把這類解釋型變成語言的解釋器
給編譯到Web3.0
然後這樣你就能夠比如舉個例子
在Learn器上去運行一個拍賞的解釋器
這個解釋器其實是被編譯到Web3.0來執行的
然後在這個解釋器裡邊就可以去run我的拍賞代碼了
大家可能會說這個方式不是感覺就沒什麼用
因为是绕了一圈
但实际上在后面那个统计你会发现
其实目前来看
有很多很多的人在使用web assembly的时候
都会选择性的
比如说把我的quip.js
这样一个js引擎
变成到web assembly
然后在我这个数据环境中
我就能够使用js
来做一些其他的任务了
其实你会发现
其实这样的一个应用场景是蛮多的
并不是像我们想的说
OK 这只是一个没有用的事情
所以这是我们说的
两种不同类型的web3.0变成语
一种是静态类型
直接编的web3.0
一种是动态类型
我把它的解释器 编译器
给编一层web3.0
然后在宿主环境中
我就能够通过让这个解释器或编译器
来间接地去跑
我的这个动态类型语言
所以是这样的两种
不同类型的变成语言
U0就比较多了
这边我主要列了一些比较常见的一些应用领域
比如说有很多这种专门为Webassembly
去开发的这些编程与例如这边的Walt
你会发现其实它的这个元代码或者说语法结构
其实跟我们刚才看的WAT其实比较相似对吧
它其中为每一个生命的变量都指定一个具体类型
比如说我第一行的Constax
那我通過帽號這種形式給他指定SR
其實有點像Rust
然後我通過這個對韓數反映劑也是一樣的
我通過帽號這種形式也指定了SR
然後最後我把我這個韓數export出去
就能夠直接export到宿舍環境中
所以其實像Wild或Green這種韓數
這種微生語言
它的本身的目的就是說
為了能夠減輕我的這個WebAssembly使用成本
因为在这个语言开发之前
你会发现我很多的这个Web三文类的一些应用
都需要使用C或者CAJA
甚至我们说Rust这类语言来去编写这个对应的这个程序
或者代码
然后才能把它给翻译到这个Web三文类来使用
但是呢像Wild Green这种语言的出现
其实大大减化了这样一个过程
所以感兴趣同学可以去看一下
看看這個愚化層面它沒有什麼這種奇奇怪怪的東西
然後除了變成語言
其實在多媒體裡面也是說
這個Web3.0一個重要的用場景
那多媒體處理呢
其實比較有名的像這個Schools
所以這個是Google當時
這個Google內部的這個Web3.0 team
當時做的一個用來展示
Web3.0應用的這樣一個場景的應用
那你可以理解為
所以它其实是一个被翻译的
或者被编译到
Web Summit平台的这样一个Photoshop
你可以在Web端直接去对
我的图片或照片进行处理
它的速度其实很快的
大家感兴趣去看一下
除此之外
其实在Web领域
多媒体处理也是比较火的一块
比如说我们常见的直播
就把在线视频
其实你发现包括B站也是一样的
他们很多这种
这种流媒体的处理上
都會用WebAssembly來做一定程度的加速
那這個也是目前WebAssembly在Web領域的一個重要的應用
除此之外 訪人器也是一個領域
但這個領域其實用的可能不太多
比如說我可以通過WebAssembly來做一些
在Web平台上對其他的一些架構的一些訪真
比如說我介面裡的GameBoyColor
你會發現其實它在右邊其實有畫出來說
我整個技術戰是什麼樣子的
它在Ambulator这一层是通过Web Summary来模拟
我这个Game Boy硬件架构层面
它具体在执行的流程的
然后我来配合我Brother层面
比如Converse
比如说一些其他的一些事件
然后就能做到把我整个Game Boy的这样一个
你可以理解为是一个游戏机
这样一个Ambulator给搬到外国平台来使用
所以這也是Web Summit有一個存在的這樣一個擁有領域
然後語音這塊我們可能不講了
因為它可能比較難去demonstrate
比較難去展示
比如像Crosslet這種
Crosslet目前可能現在已經被archive了
但是它在之前
比如說去年的時候是很火的一個項目
那Crosslet的存在
其實使得我們可以直接在Covernet裡面
去直接调度WebAssembly这样一个容器
所以是也比较火的一个东西
然后呢 游戏引擎这块其实就比较早了
比如说Unity、Sanrio其实他们在WebAssembly开始出现
或者开始逐渐走红的初期
就已经提出了要去再自身的这样一个游戏引擎框架里去支持
比如說Unity它其實可以把遊戲發佈到WOW平台
發佈到H5平台
其實它的內部就支持說OK
那我能不能把我的一些遊戲中運行的一些核心組件
核心邏輯以Wav3的形式來去做執行
做去發佈
然後的通修方式來加速
我整個的這樣一個遊戲的進行效率
其實Unity和Unreal是比較早期的
游戏引擎方面
Website的一個實驗廠
他們很早就加入了Website這個隊伍中
去嘗試來用Website做一些
性能加速方面的一些內容
然後除此之外
像IMO.js也是一樣的
就是說我最開始是用
js寫的一些物理引擎
那目前呢
因為物理引擎是一上
涉及到大量的數學運算
那其實對於中間
計算邏輯比較複雜的地方
那我們能不能夠通過
把它編譯成WAP3.0來做一個加速
所以這也是說遊戲引擎領域WAP3.0已經應用了
然後區塊鏈一太坊 大家也不懂得說的
一太坊的Engine它是用WAP3.0來寫的
這也是比較我的一個領域
然後除此之外還有一些實驗性的前輪框架
前輪框架領域是實驗性的
比如像這個SMDOM,像U這種
就是你可以通過Rust來寫前端邏輯的這樣一個框架
你會發現其實他們都在慢慢逐漸嘗試的說
通過WebAssembly能不能過去編寫一些
我的性能更好的前端應用
但是目前需要注意的是說
由于Y怎么的GCE占益proportor还没有一个比较实质性的进展
导致其实我在这些外部的modeal里面
其实没法去直接操作DOM的
其实这个就是成为了一个目前比较棘手的一个问题
像右下角的框架 还是到另外一个问题
就是说我用Rust来写前阵应用本身
这个东西是不是故为明题
因为我们都知道Rust的学习手本是蛮高的 对吧
那我不太清楚说真正在这个生产环境中
或者在现实的这些team里面
有没有team是真正用U这类框架来去写前端的
因为这个可能是很多问题
比如说整个团队的这个不同人员的这个能力
它是不是能cover这样一个东西
然后这个项目如果说我这个team
比如说人手固定的那些同学走了之后
他的可费物性会有什么影响
那这个都是说这些前端框架他在生产实践中可能遇到的一些问题
但是我觉得作为一个试验性的一个领域
他们是比较不错的
大家感兴趣可以去看一下这些框架
还没有意思
然后其他的就比如说LT我们也有一些简单的一些框架
使得我们可以在一些硬件平台上来去用Wyzen作为一个交流数据
這樣一個一個一個一個中間界的形式來存在
然後其他的比如說編輯啊 虛擬機啊
這些工具 一些圖靈相關的內容
這裡我就不展示
因為這個就比較多了 對吧
像什麼One Some Time呀
其實大家可以隨便一搜到很多的
這裡我就不夠的介紹了
然後呢 我們來看幾個
One Some在這個生產實踐中的一個案例吧
那第一個其實是
我之前也很長了很多次的
一倍使用的這個One Some案例
因为应该是我知道的
最早把Web3的用戴生产实践中的一个公司
其实他们的公司Kate是很简单
他们说我想要做一个能够在Web6.7上使用的二维码散码器
他们最初的方法是说OK
那我可能说用JS来写一个
对吧 写一个这样一个散码器
然后去扫
然后他发现了JS实现的这样一个散码器
在某些特性的场景下它的识别率不够
然后这个时候他们的开发员员说
ok 那既然我自己写的这个东西不行
那我能不能说
我把一些业界优秀的这个
200码识别库
给他稍微弄一弄
比如说我们这边列的第一个
FITBAR 其实是业界比较知名的这样一个
200码三秒气的一个库
他们会他们尝试着说
ok 那我把他
比如說這個編譯成 Web3 尾
然後我單獨去跑
然後他們發現 OK Zbar 其實單獨去跑的話
整個識別率還 OK
但是也有一些固定的 case 是沒法 cover 的
然後最後他們想要解決方案
OK 那既然我一個單個的酷
都沒法完成我的需求
那我們能不能同時去亂多個酷
然後來一個這種 racing 的方式
來去說哪一個酷識別到了
我就用哪個庫的這個反覆的result
所以你會發現他們的方案是說
我最後呢
我可能開三個Worker現成
在我的前段WRB專頁的企業裡
然後每個Worker用一套不同的方案
比如說我這前面兩個是用ZBar
和一個自己用CIAJACI的Custom Lab
來去跑
然後第三個呢是用我JS這個方案來跑
這樣的其實有個好處就是說
如果說在某些平台上OK
我不支持Rub assembly
那我的JSLAB就能够做一个降级 做一个保证
那如果说我这个平台支持WAP三倍 能够去跑
我这个流量器比较高级 它的版本比较高
那这个时候我就通过reason的方式
让三个线程同时对这个目标的RMA进行扫描
然后哪一个线程最先拿到了结果
就把这个结果给到我
所以这个是一倍最后在线上使用的一套方案
因为发现其实这个方法还是比较make sense对吧
其实他们通过最后的这样一个实验数据也发现了
其实整个的这个实验效率还是蛮高的
然后这里面你会发现其实也体现
Libre Summit一个比较重要的特征
就说它其实可以让你把一些业界
已经有的SeqCaZA的代码库
直接编一层Libre Summit来使用
而不用说我再重写
比如说我要从零开始重写这样一些东西
所以这也是WebAssembly在reuseable
会说reuseability就是可重用性这个角度的一个重要的体现
然后这边我给了一个截图
这个是他们博客里贴出来的
他们最后识别的一个效果
一个生产上的一个具体的一个截图
一个实用的截图
然后第二个例子是Shopify
他们用的其实是把WebAssembly用在Nailing
用在ColourNailing云端了
其实你可以理解为
他们这个方案其实也比较直观
他们想要说
他们的业务特点是说
他们希望说给到一些商家
一些用户
他们能够去自己提供一些业务逻辑
这样一个能力
也就是说Shopify可能说
他在自己的客楼里面
去提供一些这个接口
然后我的一个商家
他可能根据我自己的不同的这个
比如说卖东西
再让一个优惠 或者一个时间段 等等一些因素
然后制定自己的优惠策略
但这些策略是一种可编程的方式来进行操作的
也就是说你可以编辑的代码
然后在不同的情况下
去调用Shopify提供的不同的接口
来去完成你整个的这样一个活动
但是我们知道其实商家用户
他们提供的这些代码
我们理解为他们是不受信代码
因为用户它可以
作為一個UserInput,它可以去提交任何種類的代碼
其中可能會有一些Molaceous Code,比如說有一些病毒的代碼
或者是惡意操作的代碼
所以Shopify提供的方案是這樣的
他們說,我的這個用戶呢,那你可以用比如說Sunderscript來去編繫你的代碼
然後這個代碼會被編繫成WebAssembly
那實際上其實用戶用什麼代碼,用什麼來寫其實不重要
就是Nikki和Santa也一起
只需要最後說你這個代碼能夠編輯上web assembly
就ok了
然後呢Shopify在它的Cloud那邊去提供了一張一個lucid
實現的一個容器
這個容器本身跟操縣是隔離的嘛
其實我們Nikki別以為是一個shuffle環境
那首先第一步
通過這種shuffle環境
我們就用確保說
用戶的哪怕有monetious code
它至少不會把整個的cloud環境給污染掉
它又現在shuffle環境中
我們就確保說
然后它所有的操作都是安全的
所以这是第一步
我通过提供Lucid上一个Code Execution Service
然后去执行我的Wise and Banner
Wise and Banner在这里执行了也是比较安全的
这是第一步
然后Shopify通过第二步
第二个方式
也是纳美进程式方式
我就没列出来的
通过纳美进程式上
Lucid在真正执行这些Wise and Banner的时候
就能够通过WiseBanner的ImportSection
我就能够知道OK说你的WiseModule
想要去使用哪些特权
通过这种方式 其实如此就可以追踪
比如说我通过监控发现
我某一个WiseModule执行出现问题了
但是我们可以通过它的ImportSection去发现
它是不是有用到了一些
它本身没有权限去使用的一些接口
通过这种方式我们能够从另一个方面来保证说
我的Yzone module在执行的时候
它的Dependency是可靠的
它的权限是OK的
所以这是第二层在安全性层面的一个体现
然后除此之外其实Shopify使用Yzone
还有另外一个考量就是说它希望性能是足够的
这个其实我们有讲过是吧
相對於GSI來說 其實通過這種AoT
或者這種方式 我們能夠把Wizone Module
提前編繹成這個
基於某種平台這樣一個優化的機器嘛
然後通過這種
就是Wizone Module本身的設計內心的一種OnePass
可以做OnePass Validation的這樣一個模型
也就是說 我這個編繹器
再去梳理整個Wizone Module的內容的時候
我不用去Fallback到之前的代码
也就意味着我可以从这个wise module的第一个字节
开始Ish的往后去scan就OK了
那我知道我scan到最后一个bat的时候
我整个的wise module它整个结构
就能被完全扫描出来
而不再需要说我在回退到之前的某一个地方
所以这个是它one pass validation的一个表状的特性
那通过这几点因素结合
你会发现其实Wizom 它本身的性能还是能够满足业务要求的
所以这是Shopify在性能层面的考量
然后第三个考量也就是我刚才讲的时候
Wizom 其实它作为一种抽象的虚拟机指令机
它其实支持多种端语言
我们刚才讲除了Summon Script
Sigxiajia Rust 都是可以使用的
所以这就使得我们的这个
接入坊它的語言環境是不受限制的
你可以使用多種語言來完成你的任務
所以我們說這個Shopify在Cloud Native或是Cloud端的
這樣一個應用
OK 接下來我們來看一下
Website的提案和一些圖領相關的內容
Website 300 POST MAP其實是在MAP之後的一些提案
其實我這邊歷了很多
那在目前這個2020的時間節點
我們可以看到其實有29個這個Proposal
是在行進中的
相較去年就發現其實Face 3
就是第三個Face的這些提案的數量會多了很多
那第三個Face呢
其實主要是這個由Community他們來做一些
或者說這個Browser Devendor
就是比如說Chrome啊 Safari啊
等等這些Browser的這個提供商
他们来做实现implementation
这个地方可能时间稍微会长一些
当我第三步实现之后
通过Facebook我就能够把这13个提案
加入到我的Web3的标准中了
所以我们可以看到其实这13个提案
其实胜利在望
如果这13个提案完全能够加入标准中的话
Web3本身的能力会很大幅度提升
目前已经完成了TN的8个的,这个相比去年也是多了一个。
接下来我可能给大家介绍几个比较简单的TN,
因为比较负荡的TN的话,我们可能短时间内没法去介绍完。
第一个比较重要的是ExternRef的一个TN,
我也可以同一个简单的例子来给大家讲一下这个TN主要的用处是什么,
或者说主要它是怎么用的。
那我先看上面這個wt部分
wt其實我剛才講到其實是一個文本
人類可讀的文本格式
它其實內部描述了以人類可讀文本這種形式
也就是sb2式的這種形式
描述了一個wise module的內容
那這裡其實我們訂立一個函數
這個templatize上一個函數
這個函數它支持一個函數
这个参数的类型就是extra-rap
然后它接受这个参数之后
它会再返回一个参数
这个参数也是extra-rap这一个类型
extra-rap本身的它这个类型
可以用来引用各种类型的宿主
各种的宿主类型
这里的宿主也就是我们的web上的类型
比如说我可以用extra-rap来引用一个
web环境上的一个js-value
比如说indefine
比如說一個Object與對象
它都可以來引用
那這個Tabletize這個
Y怎麼含述內部呢
它其實做了兩個動作
第一個動作是說
我把我的參數拿到
通過Local to get
拿到對 拿到之後呢
然後我調整了另外一個含述
也就是我們第一行
從這個宿主環境導入的一個叫
Set到MainerTax這樣一個含述
你可以看到這邊是 called
Dollar 0就是我们第一行的这个 Function
它也就是Dollar 0 这样index
然后这个引炮的函数呢
其实它的函数签名部分
跟我这个Tablet太残数其实是一样的
它也是支持一个参数
然后返回一个参数
并且这两个参数的类型都是 X Arrive
然后这个函数的应该是从外部导入过来的
外边导入过来的
所以你可以再看到我们下方在使用
這個Yzone模塊的時候,你會發現我們在這個第三行,
也就是這個Web Summary點Essence將於構在函數的第三行,
我們在名為ENV這個Module內寫了一個函數setDominalTags,
那這個函數就會導入到Web Summary將一個Module裡,
然後最後呢被這個TomplayTags函數給調用到。
那在這個setDominalTags函數裡面,
其实我们做了一件事情
就是把你传入的一个DOM节点的InnerText属性
设置成Hello World
然后把它返回出去
最后我们其实在第九行通过实力化的WindMotion中
把Tabletase这样一个函数给导出
然后通过它来调用
那调用的时候我们也是一样传入一个DOM节点
对吧
我通过CrossLayer
然后把HeaderH1这个节点传入进去
然后你运行之后你会发现其实我对于TML
我整个页面上对应了这个Dom接电
它的这个
内容就变成它的Word
所以说其实
这里的ExcelRef它出现的意义就是说让我们的这个Widem module
可以去
引用一些
Widem本身
它不认识的一些宿主环境类型
所以这是它最主要的一个作用
你看到是这几个都是这个用来引用速度的一些不透明的类型
最后呢 我这个DOM接电传入的就是我在外部设计上的一个DOM接电
那其实这个DOM接电对于Web7来说它是不认识的 对吧
但是没关系 你可以把它传到模组里来使用
但是怎么使用呢 实际上是由你的这个速度环境来决定
因为我们实际上是这个TumbleTex 间接调用了SideDomInnerTex 对吧
然后除了这个类型的ReferenceType这个Proposal
还提供了一些其他的一些函数
比如说ref.now,ref.isNow,ref.function
那这些类型就用来对这个宿主
或者说对ActionRef这样一个类型来做一些判断的
比如说判断是不是now
判断它这个值是不是存在等等的一些function
所以我们说这个是ReferenceType这样一个Proposal
然后接下来的Threaded and Atomics这个比较简单了
其实这个也是很早就出现在外面三倍posed mp中的一个提案
就是说它其实提供了一个能够让多个wizom instance来共同使用的这样一个linear memory
一个现成内存
然后这个内存的其实是基于shatter rebuffer来实现的
那通過這種方式我們就能夠做到像幼稚圖這樣的一個working model
那我可以同時in parallel去去 run多個worker
那每個worker裡都有對應的webdom instance來去做一些任務
那如果說某一個worker想要去訪問
或者說想要去使用我內存中的某一個資源的時候
那為了防止racing就是這個數據data racing這樣一個問題
那其實這個提案也提供了相對的原子操作
可以讓你去原子性的來完成一些操作
比如說我去load的一個值 對吧
或者說我去寫一個值
那都會通過這種原子操作來實現
以防止這種數據精神的問題
所以這個是比較簡單的一個提案
但它的作用其實是蠻重要的
它其實為我們提供了這樣一個
multi-threading這樣一個working model 對吧
然后接下来是Fixwise的SMD
这个也比较简单
这个就是你可以把它理解为说
我之前没有SMD的时候
那我要去做A1B1相乘
LB2相乘
这四个数和四个数的相乘
其实我需要做四遍
但是SMD的出现的时候
我们可以说把A1到A4作为一个矩阵
或者作为一个数组
来于另外一个数组
一对一的这样相乘
但实际上我在这个指令层面 经济指令层面
只有一个指令
所以我整个的执行效率会有一个很大的提升
然后配合对应的硬件
其实让我在硬件层面的执行也是很快的
它可能也是一个矩阵的一个想成的一个过程
那CMD呢 这样一个Web Summary执行
它其实目前版本是固定128位
也就是说128个Lin
那你每一个Lin 你可以
你可以把这128个Lin分为多个不同的pattern
比如说可以说每一个8成16
就是说8个8位的数
不是8个8位
一个8位的数对于16个列
这样的就是我把128分成8成16个
这样一个方式对吧
16个8位的一个数
或者我把这个128分成8个16位的数
或者分成4个3300的数
或者分成2个6岁的数
然后呢和对应的同样类型的数据进行一个相承
所以即便实际上你可以看到有四种不同的CMD的操作
那这个也是一个对Web Summit比较重要的一个特性啊
因为我们在做一些流媒体啊
或者一些这个图像处理的时候
其实你发现像素它可能就是一裂裂的
那我们如果CMD的话
我是不是在做这种图像处理的时候
它能够以更高的效率去做一些
这个算法上的一个转换呢
对吧
所以就是CMD这样一个TN
然后呢
接下来的TN是这个BuffMemory Operations
这个也比较简单
就是说之前
我们的这个编译器再去编译
像scdmemory copy
这样一些这个标准口函数的时候
这个函数就是说
我想把我的一个数据
从某一个内存位置
给它copy到另一个内存位置
那我们之前再去
用web3本来实现这个函数的时候
你会发现我都是每一个拜的一个拜的这样去copy的
那其实很慢对吧
因为我没有其他的这样一个指令了
我只能一个拜的一个拜的这样去copy
然后通过这个BalkMemoryOperations
你会发现它提供了比如说像memory.copy这样一些指令
可以让我们以一个大块的形式来把数据进行一个办议
所以我们像它是BalkMemoryOperations
那从这种方式呢 我的整个的这个内存的复制也好啊
天冲也好啊 说实话也好啊 说是drop memory等等一些操作都会
呃 以一个更高的效率的方式去完成
所以这个是啊bug memory的这样一个一个提案
ok 然后我们刚才介绍了这个
外表三蕾相关的内容 然后我们把这个话题稍微眼神一点
我们来看一下这个wisey 就是外表三蕾System interface
它也是出现在web3.0之上的一个提案
它跟web3.0本身是核心提案的
是分开的
它是独立去发展的一套
基于web3.0这样的一套
system interface标准
也就是操作系统接口标准
我们可以举个例子
来理解一下YZ到底是什么东西
比如说我们传统的这样一个接口
比如put C
这样一个标准库的一个函数 对吧
那实际上它在不同的操作系统
或者不同的OS上的实现是不一样的
比如说我在Windows上
那我可能通过Windows API
来完成我最终这个接口的一个任务
那我在Posix上或者在Linux上
我可能会用Posix API来完成这个任务
所以这个是传统抽象的接口
它在不同OS上的一个实现的一个区别
那这里体现的比如说我们
我比MUSLV这样一个标准规律
比如说它这个标准库的F-Open这样一个系统接口
它其实内部会使用比如说SysM Call
这样一些投资用调用来去完成
我最终的这样一个接口的一个任务
那你可以看到其实这个就是最终的一个调用的地方
它其实直接使用了X864上的一个SysM Call这样一个指令
所以你可以很細節的看到說
我在這個傳統的MOSI
比如說或者LabsC等等
這些提供的這些接口
它內部的實現
其實都是調用宿主環境上的
投資用調用來實現的
SysCall其實是為我們提供了
比如說針對File
或者Socket or Memory
等等一系列
跟操作系統資源相關的這些操作
那我的這個標準庫
它提供这些function也是一样的
它们最后的实现的也是通过
Tesla来实现的
然后呢websupply其实操作性的接口
也就是yzi
它其实跟我们刚才讲的传统labc的接口
其实是类似的
它其实也是提供了这样一套平台独立的
针对于yzi的系统交用接口的抽象
比如说我们这边的yzi pass open
其实它是在yzi labc这样一个库里
就去实现的
你会发现
我左边这个wazelabc就可以对标到labc上去
那它可以供我们的cccc程序来使用
比如说我一个c程序
那我现在要通过这个wazel接口
来open一个函数
open一个open file
那我就可以通过这个掉入wazelabc中的这个wazel pass open
来去操作我这个速度上的一个文件
然后这个东西在编译之后呢你会发现
OK,它实际上是对应到我的这个Virtual Machine中的这样一个定义的
所以从右边这个图里可以看到,其实最开始Virtual LabC提供了签名
就左边这个Virtual Machine Pass Open
然后我在Virtual Banner里中去用这个Virtual Machine Pass Open
我来使用
然后再往下走呢,你会发现我在Virtual Machine
每一个不同的Virtual Machine里面都会有
根据它当前淘汰系统对应的这样一个Virtual Machine Pass Open的一个实现
也就是一个定义
然后再往下,所有的这种跟操作性有相关的内容都会调用到我们最终的system call,也就是操作性能调用,也就是操作性能调用是最终的所有这些操作的一个源头,都会通过它来实现。
然后我们这个YZ,以YZ开头的这些函数比如YZPassOpen,它都是我们整个YZStandard中的一部分
那比如像这边的这个YZPassOpen,它其实是YZcore,YZ本身也分很多模块嘛
因为这个YZCommunity他们原会在实现的时候也说完全优先级
比如说先实现YZcore里面跟file和这个networking网络相关的一些接口
除此之外,还有很多Processors,比如Processors,比如说多媒体等等,这样一些接口。
OK,那我们可以带来看一个机关的例子。
比如说我左边是wizelabc还是签名,还是wizipassopen。
那我印射到比如说我右边是wizemetime这样一个VM,它内部的实现是什么样。
我们就发现其实签名都是一模一样的
只不过我右边提供的是
当前这个Widem Time在某个平台上的一个视线
它是Rust来写的
左边这个只是提供说
我在我的英文程序中使用这个接口的时候
它的好处签名是什么样子的
所以这个是Widem Time和它这个接口
接口这个层面的抽象
和它最后的实现层面的对应的方式
OK 那Widem Time之后呢
最后我们来看一下这个Tooling相关的内容
Tooling这边其实为大家整理了一下
这个图呢其实是从web3.org还是web3.com那个网站上去解决的
你可以看到在这边我们可以看到每一种不同的engine
比如chromia,sapharia,web3.com,甚至是node.js
在web3.com这个标准层面它对不同proposal的一些支持情况
那如果说你做相应的web3.com,可以来这边看一看
看看對你的這個
如果你想要某一個feature
比如看一看你在這個
用戶的這個速度環境上
或者說生產環境上是不是支持
然後除此之外呢其實目前的這個tooling
他還目前也支持說我在瀏覽器中
Chrome裡面去調適
使用C和Ci加語言編寫的
Y怎麼應用的
那就我覺得這個也是說
Y怎麼在tooling中的一個
比較重要的進步啊
這個使得我們這個debubbing
變得方便了很多
那使用这个东西可能需要你去从Chrome Store、Web Store去安装一个插件
那这个呢大家可以去这个自己去搜一下
也比较好是安装的
当然Rust的生态呢
其实比释迦迦的其实更完善一些
但是目前呢
是不是支持在刘兰气球中去调试Rust的编写的这个Web Samurai营用
这个可能大家去稍微看一下
这个我这边可能没有一个医生的信息给给了大家
然後在Web之外的就是你發現也有很多這個進展
比如說今年的這個Web上面2.0草案已經發佈了
那裡邊已經合併了很多很多的這樣一個Proposal
然後同時Docker和Wism Edge也合作
現在如果你去Docker官網你會發現其實
那個Docker Logo旁邊會寫一個
也標了一個Wism
也就是說Docker裡面其實目前也是與Wism生態有一個比較
官方上的一個融合吧
然後同時Wism Time這樣一個虛擬機
它的1.0版本也是發佈了
這使得我們可以真正的在生產中去使用
這樣一個虛擬機的一個能力
然後除此之外包括 module linking and interface types
等等提案的以下不斷地實現的
包括社區
這個 bad code lines 社區也是在不斷地做一些規範號的治理
那整個生產的還是向好發展的目前來看
然後最後我們來看看這個
這個 web sample 2020年的 2020的一些情況
那我这边也是分了几个角度来看看
我们一起来过一下
从不同角度来看
说这个这个整个情况什么样子的
那从目前使用的语言情况来看
其实RAS还是稳制帮手的
那出乎意料的是
GRC语言呢其实被排到了第二
GRC语言本身它没法被编译成 WebAssembly
但是为什么会放在这边
这是由于说,像我刚才讲的,有很多这种scenario,有很多场景是说,我需要用GS来作为我的客户短语言,来去操纵我的其他的一些特性,但是为了能够让GS在Web3美中去使用呢,那我就需要把GS引擎整个给编一层Web3美,然后通过这种方式来去让GS成为速度语言,可以去控制我整个系统,
系统其他方面的功能
所以从这种方式你会发现
JS它的使用的广泛程度或者接受程度
它排在了紧随Rust的位置
然后CIA-JANA其实整体看来是中间下滑的
虽然说是首个支持的语言
但是其实用它来编写
W300应用的人是越来越少的
那除此之外
还有一些比较小众的语言
比如Grain
这种专门为Y怎么支持的语言
还有Zig这种也是比较少的语言
然后如果再问到说未来你对希望的手拿这种语言
你会发现前两名确实不变的
第一名还是Rust
然后第二名也是js
然后通过这种讯击的方式来去使用
那CIA加的语言也是逐渐往后排
就是你会发现Go和Blazer也是排在了CIA加的前面
CIA加的还是使用热情的数据降低的
然后除此之外的其他的语言也都纷纷有上伯
比如Python,Java,Zag,Wat,Grain,Helps with Ruby
也是有人在使用的
然後通過這個統計可以看到
其實Rust本身還是使用率還是本不上升的
那其他語言整體來說還是有所下滑的
然後Blazer和Python
Blazer和Go這兩種語言
其實相較於去年的使用人數是有所增長的
然後從目前的使用場面來看
但其實你會發現還是外部應用最多
因為Web三本人起源於外部
我覺得外部應用最多
這是正常的一個現象
但是Serverless和雲應用也逐漸增多的
隨著Web三本人和Docker和Whatsom Edge
等一些虛擬機的這些結合
就發現我在雲應用
就是Quarnitive或者說容器化等等一些場景
那Web三本人使用的也是逐漸增多的
但這個趨勢也很明顯的
同時同意可以看到其實Serverless
还有contemporization就是容器化
这两个方向是逐渐增加了
外部上的使用频率是有所下滑的
然后我最后来看看你对其他的新特性
这边我就不一个个去过了
其实这边利用的所有特性
大部分应该都已经在stage 3
stage 3 长于阶段了
那我相信你其实不用过太久的时间
我们就能够在各种环境
或者虚拟机中去使用它们
你可以看到牌子最前的是Strength
然后GC的意义是大家关注的焦点
因为GC的出现能够使BIB3的应用场景
就会有更大的扩展
所以大家也是关注GC的一个发展情况
然后还有哪些要提升的地方呢
其实随着YZ用来读
你会发现Number of the APN
是逐渐大家觉得是需要进一步去优化的一个地方
然后除此之外
还有就是项目的调试和构建能力
也就是debugging、tooling相關的內容
因為我的項目洗完之後
我沒法去很好的做調適
這個也是不太好用的一個地方
然後除此之外還有外部接口也是說
大家去希望能夠提供更多外部接口
再一些能力
然後擴展外部三倍在外部生態的一個能力
也是大家覺得需要去進一步提升的一些地方
但是其他地方也有很多
我覺得整體來說外部三倍本身的這個從各個方面來看都是在
逐年的吻不得去完善的
当然可能还需要一些时间去完整的去做到能够去生产来使用
然后最后因为我们有点超时了
最后我还是给一个观望建议
这个建议其实最近两天没有变化
因为前几年有师傅在分享Web3美术
还会换一些其他的一些这个建议
现在建议还一样
就是大家可以持续去关注这个东西
然后根据你的生产
根据你的这个team情况
选择性的使用
因为已经有很多公司已经用在生产
比如说这张B站
所以他们已经用在生产了
我觉得大家的根据自己的情况
也可以去选择新鲜使用
这个是没有什么问题的
好的 那我的分享到这边就结束了
感谢大家耐心听我报道完这些内容